i mean i feel very grateful to be where
i am today
i don't really look back and think about
that kind of stuff christina anstead
is moving forward less than a week after
announcing her split from second husband
ant anstead the hgtv star was all smiles
with ex-husband tariq al-musa while
filming the upcoming ninth season of
flip or fluff
i think it'd be nice because we expanded
to add a little pop of color
oh no you're serious look how nice that
looks together purple and gray
what are you serious i'm just kidding oh
gosh what are you doing to me
christina and tarek were married from
2009 to 2018
and shared two children taylor and
braden after her split from tauric
christina tied the knot with aunt with
whom she welcomed her third child
hudson last year and i know that you
guys have kind of talked about you know
your love story happened pretty quickly
he said i love you quick you guys found
each other and got so happy so fast
was was baby always on your mind or was
it planned or i don't know you tell me
no it wasn't it wasn't on our minds i
mean it's something that if it happened
it happened but we definitely
you know was not something that we said
we want a baby right now
so it just happened quickly christina
took to instagram
friday to announce her separation from
ant writing
we are grateful for each other and as
always our children will remain
our priority we appreciate your support
and ask for privacy for us
and our family as we navigate the future
tariq has also been keeping busy
in august he got engaged to selling
sunset star heather ray young
listen i know you're thrilled this is a
dream come true how does it feel for it
to be here
you knew this was gonna happen since the
moment you met this man
you know i didn't know when though we've
we've talked about marriage throughout
dating the last year but it was never
like something
we never talked about like seriously
like we dabbled in it we talked a little
bit about like oh
where would we want it and but actually
like the last few months he's been
talking more and more about it
but i still i didn't think he was going
to do it on our one-year anniversary i
thought he was going to wait maybe like
you know a couple months after
and um so i was actually very very
shocked
also in addition to working with tarek
christina spent time celebrating their
daughter's 10th birthday with a paris
themed party
which she shared photos of on instagram
christina spoke with et about balancing
work
and motherhood in 2014. how do you
choose
when it's mom time and when it's
designer time and when it's tv star time
and when it's you know i think i just
take it one day at a time i do try to
schedule out the week
and i do make sure that when i get home
like i'm done
you know that's why my emails can get
really backed up because i just like
when i get home i need to be totally
present for the kids like there's just
way too much going on so that's a big
thing and then on the weekend same thing
just like make sure that we're doing
lots of family time
my kids love like little things like
board games i love swimming
so thank god for the pool and that keeps
them busy and distracted right
it's just it's just one day at a time
you